American audiences may not realize just
how much of a big deal you are I you
have a Michelin star restaurant you've
got culinary schools you are a huge deal
how did you get involved with the Great
British baking show well you know I
before I was on the great baking show I
was on the great the Great British menu
was a television program great menu
which was a competition for top chefs
and top restaurants and I did that for
11 years and so I had done an awful lot
of eating very good food and they each
cooked every one of these chefs would
cook a four course meal and we'd have
three of them in the morning and three
of them in the afternoon so that was
much more difficult than eating cake
people think you know eating so much
cake must be exhausting but you know you
can taste the whole of a cake in a
teaspoon you can get in one teaspoon you
can get the the Cake The Filling and the
icing all in one mouth is if you've got
a chef doing a main course and he will
have you
know um a main say a piece of fish or
something then it'll have a sauce on it
and it'll have be accompanied by some
kind of vegetable and then there'll be a
you know there'll be drizzles and Foams
and God knows what else and this will
happen for the first course and the main
of course and the dessert and the Savory
so it's um to me the baking shows a
holiday after the great brish menu and I
and I think I got the job because the
boss of Channel 4 um who who did both
shows wanted me to move from one to the
other so she
did she fingered me that was
good and then and then of course um um
Paul used to do the Great American
baking show before Roku had it and and I
didn't because they always had an
American judge then they decided to swap
and have two British judges so then I
buled in so that was good and honestly I
prefer it that way you know yeah bring
the show to America but I need my
British judges I need
that good well I'm glad of That So
speaking of the differences what would
you say the differences are now that you
are part of the um Great American baking
show what are the differences between
the two would you say excluding
celebrity aspect of it but yeah the the
Americans and the British do you know
there's much less difference than I
thought there would be um when I
first when somebody first suggested to
me you ought to have a look at the Great
American baking show I I thought no
it'll be awful it'll be like I'd seen
lots of American competitive shows where
the competitors are so competitive and
they're so in your face and they are so
determined to win and they're quite up
to sabotaging
their you know their Rivals and crying
foul and um generally behaving when a
way which is very un um British Bake Off
and so I thought I wouldn't like it but
I I shouldn't have because there's
something about that
tent that people walk into the tent and
they just behave like everybody else
they're I mean the Americans walked in
and immediately were friendly to each
other and they catch the because I mean
the crew are very nice and everybody's
friendly to everybody else I mean I I've
worked now on bov for seven years and
I've never heard anybody you know bad
tempered quarrel or shout at each other
or anything none of that and um
and I think the the I think it's
probably because anybody who applies to
go
onto the Great American baking show will
have
watched the British Bake Off and so they
have a very good idea of what it's like
and and they adapt you know they just
adapt they just are nice people and I
must say I was surprised because they're
every bit as nice as the
Brits you know it's been fun I love that
and it's true I think you know I mean
for me personally and I a lot of people
I've spoken with we watch great Great
British baking show because it feels
like a warm blanket and like a warm hug
and it's like we don't have to see
people be mean to each other we just
want everybody to be nice to each other
because AB right most reality shows are
that so I I love that I love that yeah
but that says the says say that's
exactly what the baking show is like the
American baking show it's a and it's
really important that it's that that it
is and I think Love Productions after
all make both shows and make a few all
over the world um and if they make them
they even even when they're franchised
they keep a very close eye that they
don't
become um loud and brutal and you know
unkind because I think it is their U USB
I think it is why people watch both the
baking show and bake off is
because it's it's it's an Escape From
the rest of the world which at the
moment is not very nice very true very
true it's so good to be able to watch
people be kind to each other more of
that need more of that um so speaking
you mentioned Loud Let's talk about the
celebrity I had to say that uh what were
your expectations for the celebrities
coming in because it's not the so it's
not the typical home Bakers who do this
well I mean generally celebrities tend
not to be great Bakers I mean they're
there because they're they've been asked
to do it and and because they think
it'll be fun usually because they watch
bake off and so they they've accepted
the invitation because they thought oh
I'd love to do that because because they
love the show so they they're they
already understand what the shows like
and they want to do it but they're not
great Bakers generally and um and of
course they tend to be very busy so they
probably haven't practiced they might
have been some of them sometimes haven't
even read the recipe before they arrive
because of course they can choose their
own recipes and they can do a lot of
work before if they want to and some of
them do and um and then it's wonderful
and it shows you know when they've been
practicing and they know what they're
doing but it's usually the ones who
already are good bakers who have who
practice the ones who've never baked
think this is no time to start they'll
start on the show and so they have a you
know and we have home economists who
sort of they don't do it for them but
they do sort of remind them do you think
you ought to just look in your oven or
do you
um those egg whites are they going
anywhere you know they'll sort of
they'll help a bit you know because they
got to end up with something but it's
not it's no and it's not as serious
because we because we know that this is
not going to be a life-changing decision
I mean for some people if they win the
main show the Great American baking show
they could become professional Bakers
they could find themselves with a t TV
show they could find themselves I mean a
lot of the the British B um winners have
gone on to have food careers when theyve
started life as accountants or Engineers
or or nurses or something so it it can
be life-changing so it's
really um important for them but for the
celebrities is not so important because
they've already got a good job that they
love um and so it is the atmosphere is
generally more relaxed Paul and I are
more relaxed because it doesn't really
matter
um it's not so important to the to the
contestants as it is
[Music]
in in the main shows that makes a lot of
sense there's the stakes are lower so
there's more freedom right yes yeah
exactly you put it very well better than
I have oh no you did a great job I was
able to no no summarize like a good
journalist get exactly that's my
job thank you so much for taking the
time to chat with me today PR I love
getting to listen to you and your your
wisdom and just knowing the career
you've had it's you know I'm not a baker
I'm a cook I'm trying to become a baker
but I
know it's a it's a struggle but that's
why I watch so I can get oh good thank
you well good luck and thank
you